Cómo entender este concepto que se
conoce como discriminación positiva
porque de alguna forma se menciona la
palabra discriminación Dentro de este
Así es conocida aquí en los Estados
Unidos como la acción afirmativa
realmente viene a través de hace muchos
años ya más de 40 años la suprema corte
de justicia en el año 1978 Precisamente
en un caso de una universidad una
universidad de California confirmó que
la raza era un factor que se podía
considerar al elegir entre los
solicitantes calificados para la
admisión sin embargo en ese momento
dictaminó que la universidad no podía
reservar lugares solamente por la raza
que era ilegal esta práctica se ha
estado llevando aquí en los Estados
Unidos como digo aproximadamente por 40
años y eh
es bastante hay mucha desinformación en
lo que es realmente la acción afirmativa
hay que tomar en cuenta que la acción
afirmativa no incluye cuotas Simplemente
no tomar la oportunidad a alguien es una
idea equivocada realmente eso es lo que
se piensa pero es una idea equivocada Es
simplemente que la raza sea tomada en
consideración entre muchos otros
factores no siendo la raza el factor
determinante la acción afirmativa como
como sabemos es básicamente fue diseñada
para mitigar las consecuencias de la
discriminación racial aquí en los
Estados Unidos y por eso se permitió
importante de la aclaración ahora Qué
implicaciones va a tener la decisión de
la Corte Suprema en el sistema educativo
de Estados Unidos bueno básicamente la
corte ha dicho que no pueden usar la
raza básicamente dijeron que no podían
emplear la razas de manera negativa eh
involucrando estereotipos raciales y
básicamente dicen que la corte dijo que
no nunca ha permitido ese tipo de de uso
de la Raza en las ambiciones de las
universidades sin embargo en la opinión
el el juez Roberts que fue el juez que
dictaminó y leyó la la
lo que conocemos hoy como la decisión de
la corte básicamente dijo que nada en la
opinión debía interpretarse como una
prohibición a que las universidades
pudieran considerar discusiones de los
aplicantes en las cuales los aplicantes
pudieran decir si ellos se consideraban
o tenían algún en el pasado habían sido
discriminados o cuál había sido su
experiencia con la raza o con cualquier
otra desigualdad O sea que
que es ahora de las universidades que ya
de hecho la universidad de Harvard y la
universidad de Carolina del Norte que
fueron las universidades demandadas y
por las cuales este caso fue llevado a
la suprema corte de justicia han dicho
que tomarían los pasos
necesarios para poder cumplir con lo que
la suprema corte está diciendo para
tener un cuerpo diverso en la
universidad o sea diversamente eh con
todas las minorías y racialmente diverso